on s'active à installer la clôture mais
la nouvelle cour de l'école notre dame
du foyer ne sera pas prête à temps pour
la rentrée
je m'attendais à pire jeu content de
constater que l'asphalté quand même me
sont les côtés alors j'imagine que les
élèves vont pouvoir au moins profiter un
peu la récréation dans une cycle
l'agrandissement de l'école cristaux roy
sera complétée avant noël comme prévu
mais la cour d'école aura du retard avec
une quarantaine de projets
d'agrandissement et de construction qui
sont menées de front la commission
scolaire de montréal impose donc à
plusieurs directions d'école
cette cohabitation avec un chantier
c'est vraiment une tâche supplémentaire
c'est souvent un phénoménal gérer le
projet gérer le matériel qui peut
manquer gérer les parrains satisfait
gérer les personnels qui sont dérangés
les sommes investies dans la brique et
le béton ces dernières années donne
maintenant des résultats concrets les
élèves vont s'installer dans une
douzaine d'écoles a grandi et dans deux
écoles reconstruit l'école sainte
catherine de sienne dans notre dame de
grâce et l'école saint nom de jésus dans
schlague à maisonneuve fermer en 2012 à
cause des moisissures à 20 le ça peut
aller jusqu'à cinq ans pour des
agrandissements des constructions
là on est passé à trois ans et demi le
quand on calcule tout le processus
avec 1200 élèves de plus que l'an
dernier on cherche aussi à accélérer la
réalisation des projets à laval deux
nouvelles écoles ouvrent leurs portes
judy dont celle du boisé sept ans après
avoir obtenu le financement de québec
on n'est pas capable de construire aussi
rapidement que que l'on voudrait parce
que pas de possibilité d'avoir accès à
des terrains alors la commission
scolaire de laval tente maintenant
d'anticiper l'emplacement de nouvelles
écoles avec la ville et veut aussi
recruter plus de technicien en bâtiment
pour s'occuper des projets on a un peu
plus de 500 millions
donc il faut faire autrement on devra
engager du personnel à nos ressources
matérielles mais encore faut-il trouver
ce personnel on est en concurrence avec
tous les domaines où il ya de la
construction est bien souvent dans le
milieu scolaire les salaires sont moins
intéressants si ces locaux sont prêts
pour accueillir les élèves moyennant
quelques travaux de finition
c'est maintenant le souci d'avoir un
titulaire pour chaque place le matin de
la rentrée qui inquiète les directions
d'école ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal